what's up everyone a Persia here again
and this is part two of our inspiring
islands tour we are gonna check out the
next two that we've had lined up and if
you missed the first two then be sure to
check that out as well let's get going
I am actually here with eka from a pork
belly so yeah tell us a little bit about
yourself when I'm not playing Animal
Crossing I run a game studio out of
Seattle call adder loop games we made a
game called Falcon age that came out
last fork belly yes so this pink brick
area I wanted to have like a playground
and I'm more festive area so we have the
teacups
a couple stands upper machine and so
organized like it's very pleasing to the
eye
your that was something I saw in your
video your basketball
I spent let's see how many tiles is that
that's a lot of tiles 23 files oh my
goodness that that's a lot of dedication
to this court honestly it's one of the
best-looking ones cuz this rounded part
right here the arch is always the really
hard part
yeah and did you make these with like a
converter or just through the editor
looting it so when I first started
before I got the store stuff where you
can make you know in standard things
that I ended up doing through just um
you know on PC then uploading and I've
gotten more used to doing it in and the
editor yeah how do you feel about the
in-game editor as a designer in real
life it's it's great I wish there was an
option to rotate patterns instead of
doing one corner have to do all four
corners oh no I got rid of my soccer
ball this side I want to put a little
cord locks this is also a custom tile
I'm so jealous of everyone says cool
items like that so what did you design
for us here Islander your home I feel
like people usually do one of the red
one or the other so I did the island
first my home was a mess cuz that I
ended up reshaping it as I went
I didn't have a whole lotta mo I was
trying to build up things based on what
I had so the living room was really
eclectic where is the kitchen area I'm
gonna get into it's still so cozy oh yes
how does it change just have your own
cooking shows in here I started making a
custom icons to put my cheese early on
oh I see the peach like so cute I have a
peach Island so I love that one so much
the pear is adorable dog yes so I don't
want to step on that scale I'm gonna
swiftly avoid I love it this wall tiles
it's so cool perfect yeah this chair too
is so simple but it's like the perfect
theme for this room right yeah coach
sits and yells at you and your box
exactly this is definitely my kind of
color palette that's cool yeah it's kind
of like I you know I look for the
wallpaper and floor tiles and find a
good color theme and then try to seem
other objects around that oh but you
have the only cabinets that matter let's
go I got that from a friend the other
day oh man your wallpaper is super cool
I was trying to find out use for it oh
yeah it's lights up at night I mean it
went in the dark so like change the
light there Ryan gives me resident evil
vibes for some good oh I love this room
oh my goodness a bedroom I was trying to
find the most eccentric items and but
I'm pretty busy I want to nice little
bamboo pattern stuff here and then I was
thinking about like a I don't know what
this is yet but like a little station
with a cod and listen to alien signals
or something I don't know
yeah we're searching for extra steel
like
out here we're gonna get our first like
alien villager from outer space to come
and stay well that concludes our tour of
pork-belly which was absolutely amazing
thank you so much yeah it's been it's
been a real treat this games it's it's
pure joy for me to be able to play it
and I you know hang out with friends and
trade things I'm like just like visiting
other people's Islands it's been great
so much and everyone if you want to
learn more about EKKO then follow him
everywhere at Echo nots and we will see
you guys later
thank you
[Music]
we are visiting valinor next and I'm
actually here with Ally oh my goodness
this beautiful flyover already the
waterfall work Oh safe is here what's up
girl
well first off you are so adorable I
absolutely love the outfit as you can
tell I am a fan of this color palette -
I feel like I dress perfectly for the
occasion I feel like if I could be a
part of a Western film that would be I
love this the water skiing is beautiful
I already love your custom paths so yeah
I will let you take over the tour so I
actually have a little like B Center I'm
obsessed with beads like I have my own
beehive and everything could really go
pretty and you found a great use for
this iron shelf I remember when I made
it I was like where am I gonna put this
how do you feel like the terraforming
has been in terms of like you know it's
kind of like a big pixel art project but
it can also be really weird right
working with us you're escaping it is a
pain especially the water part you just
kind of keep clicking the water part
over and over and keep doing the same
spot really no I wanted like a half a
centimeter over and it likes rebuilt it
it's awful but it's I feel like it's all
worth it because you can really like
write a bunch of things I think I kind
of didn't know what to do in a lot of
spots so I just threw water on it like
that what it looks great honestly this
is a great photo area right here with a
lot of malls that nooks or
there this is the library hold on let me
get out real quick you guys I am walking
in it oh I did not think people would
like it and they did and what's funny is
this spot was just a hole I was like
this is really weird shaped because I
like put my Museum where I wanted it and
I had my stores where I wanted them and
then I just like had a weird shape whoa
I'm the mug I did not know you get mad
fantastic ten out of ten okay the bird
in the cage and everything is so amazing
um so then down here would be towards
our pier I just feel a bunch of kinda
white stuff out here it's thank you so
peaceful and gorgeous go see the sights
man you have all the best DIYs I've been
hustling it's so good it's been well
worth it I love it Wow
so cool even with the pattern on the
floor and everything Wow Wow
My Mind's exploding okay I love it but I
still kind of just based everything out
to give everyone kind of like their own
thing and then I just felt like things
weren't matching and like a filter is
great but in game play it like drove me
crazy so I just did colors for sections
and try to match it with like people's
houses Oh gotcha so yeah it's just like
the same color flowers and whatnot I saw
the first thing I think I kind of that
has to stay even though it's not
aesthetically pleasing and then my
favorite part is probably this little
lake secret tomb area
- Wow so nice and cozy love the mix of
like the wit the dirt with the stone
patterns over it yeah these ones are
like different stones so they have like
the moss so I just kind of did off Oh a
little fish market area is amazing I
love you that you have the music playing
perfectly to give the vibe yeah there's
the baby rocks like kind of freaked me
out but they're still perfect free
market
all right well Elise your island is
amazing I love it so thank you so much
for letting me tour thanks for checking
it out if you're not absolutely inspired
to give your island and glow up after
that then be sure to stay tuned for more
Animal Crossing new horizons content
here on gamespot it we'll be sure to do
the trick catch us next time as we
feature some of the best recreations
we've seen yet
take care
[Music]